hey hey you cannot scout you
welcome to us kaiju website question I
distinct that time Liz wants to know if
I like Lady gaga
and what's my favorite song by her
currently my favorite Lady Gaga track is
probably her new one where she's all
like something doesn't snow if I just
use more of a persona / personality
camera turns on I definitely got a
little bit different more excited a
little more energetic probably a little
more crazy - if I talk like this in real
life I people would probably commit me
but you some sort of insane ice uh
success
Kristin wants to know what celebrity I
most resemble um that's actually more of
a question I'd be asking you guys for
they're not really on a percent sure but
the one celebrity that people tell me
that I look like all the time is Cameron
Diaz get that a lot a lot very
interesting well sir lost this
questionnaire why I'm such an app with
fangirl because their products are
awesome I'm a creative person so I edit
I design I'm sorry
PC is you guys just don't do it for me
eyes like Emerald City what is the
airspeed velocity of an my kind of
question is this
this is a question for Google not me
driven Jay are you a heavy or light
sleeper let's find out
guess that answers that question
Facebook question how many bones have I
broken surprisingly I've never broken a
bone although I did fall face-first into
a step once which is why I think that my
nose is potentially crooked grace wants
me to post a picture of when I was
little
how many times a year do I dance in the
Apple Store used to be a lot more but
now I'm starting to get Yoda I believe
they might be catching on to my little
dancing and I don't think they like it
but a question
can I speak any other languages nope
this question actually doesn't make
sense because it's asking me how do I
know I just seen and last time I checked
I am her hello Bailey wants to know how
much do I wish I had a British accent oh
my goodness I wish I did I don't know if
you're right or not but my walls are
white you keep running the last episode
of ask I J asked you guys who you would
want to go on a date with and let me
tell you pretty much every comment
included either Justin Bieber or Taylor
Lautner yeah Wow here's some of your
comments yep Justin Bieber Taylor
Lautner Justin Bieber Bieber yeah okay
you get the point
this episode's question for you is I'm
gonna make some new t-shirts what do you
want these t-shirts to say or what do
you want on them leave me a comment
below and I will let you know what I
decide to pick don't forget to check out
other iJustine for some fun vlogs and
iJustine reviews for more fun tech
reviews on stuff okay that's it